[Applaudissements]
la diagonale les yvelines c'est c'est un
travail unique dans les yvelines et
peut-être en ile de france puisque la
prétention de traverser les lignes du
nord au sud la nouveauté cette année
c'est sur 100 km donc c'est un travail à
travers les chemins les sentiers pour
faire découvrir les milieux naturels et
patrie et le patrimoine des yvelines
sur cette troisième édition
[Musique]
comme d'habitude il ya un départ qui du
100 km qui aura lieu à droite boisrobert
le 80 km avec un départ d'orge russe
le départ du 50 km des étangs de
hollande qui avait été très appréciée
l'année dernière et le 20 km avec un
départ de clairefontaine ensuite la
petite nouveauté c'est qu'on passera par
exemple dans le haras national des
bréviaires car si tu as est assez
remarquable et puis bien sûr
encore des nouveautés puisque on sera
sur le 100 km sur une partie de poignées
la forêt donc avec des nouveaux sentiers
des nouveaux chemins et et puis aussi
une arrivée à ses majestueuses comme
l'année dernière au niveau du château de
port jeunesse à rochefort en yvelines
j'ai une nouvelle course puisqu'elle a
que trois ans d'existence l'année
dernière on a eu on a quand même fait
500 concurrents
l'idée c'est qu'à s'inscrivent un petit
peu dans le calendrier commence à être
connu un petit peu la prétention de ça
et on espère l'inscrire et devenir un
lieu un endroit enfin un site
incontournable et une course
incontournable d'île de france
si on peut rivaliser avec l'eco trail
mans va pas s'en priver
[Applaudissements]